next we have
Craig Holloway column Craig he enjoys
listening to music on YouTube Pandora
and Spotify he loves to get turn up turn
with friends be around this on it like
this when nothing sword he must
volunteer for community service please
get it up for Craig alright so i have
this paper but because i like to get
turnt up I don't want to keep going and
I don't ever shut up so I have to have
this paper that keep me on and go anyway
what's up everybody first of all how are
you good what's that what's up so again
my name is Craig Holloway I'm a PhD
student fourth-year PhD student in the
Department of Sociology here at Yale and
I'm going to talk to you today about
quote unquote my road to science so how
I got into science and what it is that I
do so the first thing I want to say and
tell you is how it is that I'm a
different dude as you can see right here
you have all of these balls it looks
sort of like eggs actually and there's
just one that is very different from all
of the rest so it's a couple of things
that make me different number one
geography I'm not from the north and
people always say I have the day that
says he didn't ask me was i from the
south he said what part of the South are
you from and so I from that bama and
with Georgia Mississippi Tennessee it we
call that the dirty south can anybody
say that the dirty south so that's what
I'm from so my accident is somewhat
different I don't say hello how you
doing this morning good to see I said
what so how you doing my name Craig I'm
just going to be the part later what I
do and so my accent is different I'm a
different do also unlike many of the
people who all of the actual other
guests who are here today to present to
you I'm a logical or natural sciences I
don't study chemistry I don't study
biology immunology etc I studied
sociology here you saw first lot so I'm
a different dude in that way and thirdly
I'm a Japan dude because I'm
man I'm a brother I come from the old
school I don't look my age I was
conceived in the city so I my old school
black panther birth is there anyway so
I'm a different do because I'm a brother
and even for example there's many places
that I go and sometimes I'm either one
of the few people of color that includes
Hispanics an agent or I'm one of the few
black and in many cases I'm the only
black man in this crowd hence i'm a
different dude in my department
currently in my department currently and
four years now i have been their own
flat man in my entire ph.d program
that's getting ready to change but four
years that's been the case but i'm in
sociology now but it actually didn't
start out that way i started out in
college as a biology at nutritional
double major since I was in seventh
grade around your age actually before I
was always interested in studying
medicine I was very interested in the
human body I read Medical Encyclopedia
since I was probably in seventh grade I
was reading medical encyclopedia is
doing all kinds of stuff and I was
inspired by the likes of this man right
here anybody know who he is just raise
your hand you do that is who that is dr.
George Washington Carver he is a famous
scientist and he is known the world over
some people call him the peanut man's
plea did all the research with the
peanut and the sweet potato and all
these other things I was very fascinated
by this brother right here and I wanted
to like him I wanted to study science
hence all I had chemistry sex and the
chemistry sets and things like that and
the like something happened
all the way through college I would
still a double major in sciences
somewhere along the line I change what
happened well there's good news sort of
and there's bad news sort of so what had
happened was some happen
bad news when things such as this
happened like an explosion that can
destroy equipment and blah blah blah
blah blah that's the bad news good news
is psych I actually nothing like that
happened what really happened was that I
work with over the summer this was back
in nineteen ninety nine and it actually
that work that I had with kids that
summer sort of like this program here in
but it was a summer program for the
entire summer for elementary middle and
high school students mostly elementary
and middle school students and that work
that I did that summer signaled to me
that there was a change ahead that
perhaps there's something else that I'm
interested in I don't quite know what it
is but I would eventually discover the
over the course of the year when I went
back to college that actually I was very
interested in people not just the human
body and how it worked but how people
act how they behave how they interact
with one another so I changed my major
from biology and nutritional science
pre-med to psychology and it was
actually a great signal in a turn to go
a different role so now that I am a
social scientist biological and Natural
Sciences again will be the life physics
chemistry and biology but when you study
a discipline such as psychology
sociology child development these are
known at social sciences our life as a
social science was so fast from the big
from the moment I declared that major
begin to take psych classes and
sociology classes I'm telling you it was
like a light just came on inside of my
whole brain that's not why I got this
brain right here that's not why I got
this brain right here to show you the
life of a science for example people of
social sciences they study race they
study gender how girls in the record one
another how women interact with one
another how women in the Wrightwood man
how blacks interacts with whites on and
on and on and on well there was this one
study where Carol dewick she's a
psychologist she studied and show
chilled how a brain is actually not
fixed so you're not going to be thinking
the same way you have the same academics
all your like your break and actually
work like a muscle and you can
strengthen it and it can go from where
it is now cognitively to a whole
different level and she had two
different groups one group
the experiment when she gave because she
taught them how the brain was a muscle
and she gave them all of these exercises
and there was a control control group
where she did not do that with
eventually she compared along with her
colleagues those two groups and she saw
that the group that was taught the brain
was like a muscle actually got better
they did better in school they did
better on standardized tests everything
changed the group that were not told
that and believed that the brain was
fixed and could not grow and strengthen
they actually remained the same so it
wasn't a matter of that being true it
was about how they thought about
themselves psychologists actually
studied that so that sort of the life of
a social sciences these are some of the
things that we study now the social
sciences are sometimes called soft
sciences and what they studied
biomedical chemistry etc are known as to
some as hard sciences some people see
these as totally disconnected but
actually that's not true there's a link
between the soften the hearts this for
example how the social science can or
does social science help heart sizes or
how does it interact with the hard
sciences this is the group of laboratory
heart scientists who work for a company
pharmaceutical company he talks about
cancer in all those drugs so these will
be the people who actually create those
drugs they make them they make it
aspirin an advil everything else you can
think about as a social scientist if I
came in the midst of this hard science
group what I would be interested in the
first thing we notice is that this is a
first group you have men right here
right there you have women right here
right here and right here you have
people who appear to me to be of
different ages you also have
particularly someone or a number of
people who may not even from the United
States and maybe be from different
countries such as the first speaker is
not Mexico I also noticed this sister
right here
she's like that eh she's standing out
she's dead like me so as a social
scientist I would want to understand all
of the experiences that they have in
their laboratory for example what type
of experiences do we have with these men
that's gender what type of experiences
do the men have with the women
experiences do the older group have with
the younger group what type of
experiences does this sister right here
have it as a concern is a race how
they're very interested in that and all
of this actually help to understand how
they interact and how they function
inside of their laboratory which makes a
big difference in how their experiments
turn out because who they are goes into
that laboratory I can even tell your
story here many stories of how people
don't have good experiences sometimes
they have great experiences in their
labs and what I see is all the sociology
and psychology behind why their lab
works the way it does another example
hard science how to help sauce science
just give you a simple example germs
everybody all right now I'm a social
sciences sociologist who work with
people who goes out into an environment
I could be studying you're actually I
have been since I've been here I've been
studying this whole crowd and so I shake
hands all the time I'm touching door I'm
around people in different cities and
schools in corporations and skyscrapers
there's talking to people studying
people interacting with people well and
often and all this work that I do that's
a lot of germs I'm coming in contact
with it would behoove me then coming
upon me to know a lot about something
simple that's germs watching a hand with
lukewarm water all things myself against
diseases that can make me a sick social
psychologist if I don't pay attention to
these things that should we learn
through hard science just give you a
simple example of how even that all
these things are actually connected now
the as you can see I used to have a pro
Bali ha and after that was me in May no
I just cut my hair recently she just
found out I know calm
and this beautiful Queen right here
here's my mother say all this old-school
G right here you can see where I get it
from is my pops they were here in May to
watch me graduate I'm not finished yet
but every PhD program gives you a
master's degree along the way it's
called an unroot degree so I got that
back in May this past May this is
rational Yale's campus in front of
sterling libraries i'm quite sure you've
seen it and we just took a picture on
the day I just decided to walk just so
they could see it now why did I put this
up here parents and mentors parents are
so important no one gets anywhere alone
and I talked about my role and I've been
talking about my road to science well it
starts here in my house where I was born
while I was raised by these two people
right here my parents also grandparents
I've had mentors along the way all of
these people have helped to get me where
I am I'm here to tell you but I didn't
come from anywhere this is a woman here
that didn't finish high school this is a
man who only finished high school never
seen the daylights of a college in its
entire life yet they have raised three
boys all of us conceived in the 70s I'm
the young accommodate
I / baby the group and they have AIDS
not only boys who went on to graduate
from high school all three of us black
boys but we also and I'm not harping on
race everybody's beautiful but this does
mean something in America because I love
all the people who drop out of high
school blackboards drop out at higher
rates than everybody else so this is
something that's very important to a
sociologist want to know what is this
all about right they raised three black
boys who all graduate from high school
in all went to college and me I not only
went to Tuskegee University while i
study initially i also went on to
Harvard University where I got my first
masters and now at Yale here working on
a PhD I just received what is my third
masters in soon-to-be PhD it took these
parents though they're not
college-educated they raised
college-educated boys it takes family it
takes mentors people outside of your
family or even within your family don't
turn them away because that's how you
get to wherever you're going to go
whether you're going to be a sucker
chemists biologists an engineer even if
you're a woman you say oh it's not a lot
of women and engineer women can't do
engineer and women can do chemistry we
got one coming up soon and she rocks
they can do that it takes all of these
people and I end with this thing there's
an African proverb that says it takes a
village to raise a child and it is true
it took a whole village to get me where
I am I come from dirt nothing from the
Hulett from ghetto proper nothingness to
where I am today which is why I can
switch it up from intellectual to hook
in like 25 seconds but if people are the
reason why with that being said love on
your parents all of your mentors love
everybody thank you
oh you may have crap questions oh my bad
quick questions and answer i hope i
didn't go over too was that good how
long was that Oh perfect any question
blah blah blah yes I answer a few
because I know we have to keep it moving
it all has a great question the most
difficult actually that's a hard
question because I had so many outs top
count most difficult obstacle I've had
to come over come I was an undergrad
when I was in undergraduate it's back in
the 90s whatever grey hair well when I
was an undergraduate student my mom got
sick so she's been she actually they
didn't see me walk to get my masters at
Harvard because she got sick again
ironically went to hospitalize her in
downtown Boston well that's why I walk
for this masters even though I'm still
your PhD just so they could see they did
see the Harvard of masters I said you
will see the Yale masters that's why i
flew him up put them in a hotel in a
suite and everything so the hardest
thing within having to get through
undergraduate and staying strong being
resilient why she would even sick back
did I had to travel two hours round trip
every day I was a full-time student and
I had a job it was rough it was very
very rough and I didn't quit now I
didn't give up I remain an honor roll
student I was on scholarship I graduated
and on the student even in spite of all
of that so that was my greatest one of
my greatest obstacles death yeah anybody
else I know one of the brothers better
ask me a question yeah i know i've got
the
and my brothers my brother's I mean any
dude in the crowd cuz I'm really
thinking about the one in the peaking
right shirt they got turned up a few
minutes ago to get I get you just try to
catch out to get your chat right any
questions and they thought anything come
on mr. turnt up no oh you with our
energetic few minutes ago I thought you
going to ask me a question nobody else
everybody good if nobody got to quit yes
sir have you continued or will you
continue to have I continued will I
could say I'm all in on this question
that's that's uh yeah that was brilliant
he said have I can will I continue are
working with kids or mike i'm still
working i've been working with him since
1999 i would I working with and for
children they will put me in my grave
that's will be on my grade he worked and
save all the kids he possibly could so
yes sir I will and part of my research
is actually would youth group all doing
focusing on fathers for my research but
you can't be a father without a child
right so even thats related to children
thank you that was a great question out
in with that